first I woke up at 5:00 hadn't dropped
then I will go back 5:20 hadn't drops
and then I will go about 6 10 and then
it dropped a few minutes after 5:20 here
we are people we're here whatever
whatever we're on top of all the Super
Bowl ones who are here now first time
let's check it out I told you we should
have watched Cloverfield instead because
everyone likes that no damn changing the
music schemes in the streets and says
nice
[Music]
I'm going to be a pilot
the best in the galaxy
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
that's yes its first crew
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
like HP Lovecraft again hey man whoa hey
John can you just watch it back just one
more time sure for safekeeping
yeah why not I was like the way that's
added it for the trailer
[Music]
well he sounds nothing like Harrison
Ford but that's okay
Hey
I'm gonna be a pilot
speak it down
[Music]
you
[Music]
it's cool about this this has like a
Western feel you know you like with him
like
[Music]
I don't know how I feel about the logo
yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
I mean what we're getting so far I'm not
as worried about the film as I once was
of course they're still like the
skepticism because of all the behind the
scenes stuff that's picking this collar
on this movie feather brigade and the
trailers are so late you know when you
know there are certain concerns about
the idea of doing a han Solo movie
there's still one thing that is really
cool about this is that even though it's
a han Solo spin-off movie they're still
giving us a whole ensemble here to get
the that in sambala brand new characters
and then some returning characters seems
like that's what could make this feel
really fresh and different and explore
new parts of like the bounty hunter
world or whatever mission they're on yes
it looks like it has a distinct flavor
distinct design but yeah you know if
anything it's more of a companion piece
to rogue one like we thought and I sort
of felt like though from the 45-second
tees that we got yeah yeah I can see
that being coming something cool you
know there's something that feels older
about this like we are flashing back to
an earlier time even yeah it is all
futuristic still and stuff it somehow
through this trailer it feels like we're
going back and telling a prequel stories
like that's kind of cool and distinct
for this like I like all the imagery a
lot the one thing this trailer what I
was hoping would really do for me was
Alden brains not fully functional right
now the one thing that was over the
trailer would do is really put my mind
at ease more about his performance and
right now that's a minute and 40 seconds
for introducing new characters you'll
get snippets
I don't feel too drawn to his
performance yet you know there's not
anything here given to me in the trailer
that I'm gravitated towards what he's
doing you know you can't help but think
of Harrison Ford and kind of want it to
be a little bit more like a young
Harrison Ford but that's what you have
to live up to and you have to capture
the spirit of Harrison Ford again it's
just the thing he has to do what he also
has to make it his own right now I don't
really feel this
Harrison Ford in his performance
simultaneously I don't know I'm not
really drawn to anything that he's
really doing right now it's like this
that this is a performance work you
really can't tell how this guy's gonna
be until you actually watch the movie
but in terms of what the movie is it
looks like this could be a pretty solid
film in a lot of other ways though it
does have this Western vibe to it like a
space Western vibe a little bit more
what I was looking for is mean because
it's space boundaries and for the
longest time I've been saying that I
kind of hope this movie is a little bit
like a live-action cowboy bebop which
it's not having a vibe to it that feels
a little bit like it could be semi
Western II makes me more drawn to this
movie I mean it gives it a distinct
looking flavor and you know I guess so
there's something about the quality of
the designs and just the aura the tone
that they're drawing here that does look
really intriguing and yeah the final
ingredient is gonna be how compelling or
not his Han Solo is you know how the
story around it works you know with the
writing and all that I mean I guess the
big question is how well is this one
teaser trailer accurately representing
the film is this the tone of the movie
or is this just a really well composed
trailer over some really cool images of
the film and I thought the music was
really cool but is this gonna be more of
this kind of serious vibe that I wasn't
really anticipating for this spin-off
movie or is it gonna be more of a fun
vibe like not as like silly or fun it's
like a gardens of the galaxy but more
along that line I just can't really tell
for sure what kind of movie we're gonna
get yeah it's actually after all the
craziness with the directors and and the
tones every concern that way there's
still a lot when I think about it to be
concerned yeah but at least it's a good
trailer yeah grabbing me with stuff I
wasn't expecting it to it's just so
gonna fill that tall order of being hot
and the other thing about it too is that
it's core to my lawrence cast and who
worked on Empire and returned the Jedi
and I can sort of feel some of his
touches on here like arguably if you're
gonna do a han Solo movie it should feel
a little bit like that yeah alright guys
well is this gonna be the greatest movie
ever
well how you feel after every Star Wars
trailer
this time I do have my like you know I
don't wanna Foley just we give it to it
right now
still Emma skepticisms but right now
right now it looks old stuff to prove
this true actually gave me a lot to look
forward to and a lot to anticipate guard
still a little up but I am really
looking forward to at least seeing it
now thanks for tuning in sorry were a
little bit later than usual this
hopefully you're still here I can't wait
to go back to bed
subscribe to the rejects click that
notification value notified every time
on reviews is up and patreon is an
awesome website where people have been
pledging lately and thank you to
everyone at patreon become a patronage
acted day plugs